on today's show we're diving deep into
the hit animated show Justice League
action plus we've got an update on the
injustice to mobile games so get ready
for DC all FS
[Music]
hey guys I'm Jason in them and I want
you more crack open a can of soda folder
because we're running up all the latest
DC news
Arsenal Roy Harper makes this triumphant
return to the pages of Green Arrow and a
new story arc called reunion
the latest issue uncovers the hidden
history behind one of DCs greatest duo
from Oliver and Roy's disastrous falling
out to their long overdue reconciliation
keep your eye on the target and grab
your copy of Green Arrow number 18
starting tomorrow
Eclair princess of crime has to stop an
all-powerful alien force from destroying
earth in all-new Harley Quinn's dork Ron
is hell-bent on taking over the world
and enslaving humanity and while Harley
distracts them the corrupt mayor is
targeting the city's homeless plus one
of Harley's former enemies is on the
loose watch New York City erupted in a
free-for-all in issue number 15 this
week a secret government program that
trains children to be lethal assassin
goes horribly wrong in a new vertigo
series called savage thing the soulless
army of killers becomes uncontrollable
leading to a rash of terrorism across
the country the only hope for solving
the crisis is they're calling the one
man who turned his back on the
organization you can sort out all the
chaos in issue number one tomorrow in
gaming news we just got a first look at
the injustice two mobile games straight
out of GDC you can hold all the power of
injustice two in the palm of your hand
from the expanded team rosters to be
upgraded gear systems to be new and
improved fighting style download the
mobile version and you'll never be bored
waiting in line again there's plenty of
new shelf candy for every brand of DC
fans coming out of toy fair 2017 Mattel
is offering a new toy line based on the
Wonder Woman movie while Funko announced
pop figures for the Justice League film
and Lego unveiled 18 new set inspired by
the Lego Batman u plus we're hitting new
line for DC superhero girls Teen Titans
go and Justice League action we might
need to start a fundraising campaign for
our DC toy obsession justice league
action in with some incredible cast of
voice actors to bring the greatest
heroes and villains to life or a new
generation of DC fans for today's
featured story we've got producer
creature to talk about what his version
of the league is like but first we've
got an exclusive clip from this week's
episode check out crazy no kidding
when we heard there was a break-in at
the watchtower who expected the invaders
deploy their weapons are real enough
who's supposed to be on watch gotta feel
Oh aren't you supposed to be guarding an
hour I know for someone who hasn't seen
it can you briefly explain what is
justice league action Justice League
action is all of your favorite members
of the Justice League and some you've
never heard of until of your least
favorite members that we're going to
reinvent into your favorite members oh
and we drop them into a Cuisinart and we
spin it around and we bring it back up
into a kid-friendly family-friendly
action show that also has ample scoops
of comedy how's that I just made that up
very well
you sold me on the show why would you
miss that yeah what kind of freedom you
have you talked about you're mixing all
these characters only different type of
genres together what kind of freedom do
you have when you're brainstorming your
stories for these hero a complete
freedom it's it's very interesting I
think that um as long as we keep in mind
that you know we can't do anything
particularly offensive we're free to
choose from years and years of DC
continuity and pluck out our favorite
bits a lot of Silver Age stuff nutty or
will reinvent modern we do some vertigo
stuff of a Swamp Thing is in there a
Constantine is in there but we've kind
of put a spin on them so they're they're
not quite as issue and I mean in the
best possible way but I need it probably
the most obscure character of all time
bass cat space cabbie is it played by
the great Patton Oswalt is in there and
you'll see him more often than you might
expect
every show you're hoping for a Fonzie
and we have like five Fonzie every time
and we'll bring a new actor into the
booth and we'll hear PJ burn firestorm
we go now him he's our breakout
character and then data Snyder will come
in and
- plastic man ago plastic man definitely
are breaking our character and and then
we have deeper Vader as a booster
booster gold and and he also is a
breakout character so it's all fun it's
all Fonzie's all the time oh I feel a
panel the week coming off well before we
go we've got one of the hottest toys to
come out of 2017 Toy Fair and that is
the Justice League rebirth action figure
seven pack and hey we're going to get
one of these to you guys yes and we're
also going to throw in rebirth collected
editions of Titans and Suicide Squad for
your chance to win all you have to do is
go to DC Comics comm /watch and win and
fill out the form it's that easy
Plus don't forget to click subscribe to
DC all access and we'll see you tomorrow
Super Friends because we have some toys
to play with